it's about that time it's time to turn
your great idea into a reality with
squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
if you want to showcase your work or if
you want to sell products of any kind
they have beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can easily
make a beautiful website all by yourself
but if you do get stuck
don't worry happens to the best of us
squarespace has 24 7
award-winning customer support that's
going to be there to help you out so
head to squarespace.com
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
a very exciting episode awaits you
ahead of this introduction for said very
exciting episode
we have two returning guests but they
came on
initially as individuals and now they
are here together they're not together
but they're best friends we have hazel
hayes and dodie clark
authors artists entrepreneurs
uh sensitive souls bleeding hearts
yoga enthusiasts yoga enthusiasts
all of it we talk about hazel hayes new
book
debut novel out of love we talk about
dodie's
secret project coming up in the near to
distant future
we talk about their friendship how they
met uh how they moved in together
and how they've survived the quarantine
together it's a really lovely episode
with two incredibly lovely goblins
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
hazel haze and dodie clark
[Music]
okay here we go i am so excited that
both of you are
back on not too deep and you're together
this time
um the question i love to ask um
people that come on together that have
been friends or
you know other situations with each
other for a while
i love to hear uh both of your
interpretations of your origin story
like the first time you guys met each
other and to see if they're similar or
different
we talked about this the other day
that's so weird
yeah okay so it's fresh in your mind so
take me through whoever wants to start
what your
uh viewpoint was of the first time you
guys met each other you know this story
like you seemed to
i did you seem to remember it very very
quickly and it went it's not as big for
me
i feel like i think you had a very
different impression of what happened
so i met hazel when i was 18
17 okay i was like 17 18.
um and i there was she was working at
google
i'm very old i think we need to open
with that because this story makes me
feel like an actual dinosaur
well i'm 35 and you're 25 so there's a
10-year gap so at the time i was like
working for google like
old grown-up adult google implies i had
to write a letter to my um head of year
to let me
um join in with this sort of course
thing that i've been invited on so i've
been invited on this sort of youtube
course
at the google hq studios and i was very
excited
just a young skippy kid and hazel
was hot hazel who worked at google she
was known as hot hazel
wow
[Laughter]
um anyway but she was like this sort of
like hot woman
who always had her nails painted always
like walk around the heels like these
awesome beautiful dresses
and everyone will be like wow that's
myself anyway i saw i saw her
like teacher figure this like womanly
teacher figure and there was one like
session where we all sat down and hazel
was like involved in a circle and i
asked for like some advice or stuff on
something i was just convinced that you
found me annoying
i really didn't she seemed like a lot of
people i get this from a lot of people
who are now friends where they're like
oh when we met i thought you hated me
and i really
probably had no opinion on them at
which is which is much better to hear is
i didn't think about you
at all in a positive or negative way
i didn't hate you you didn't even cross
my mind
yeah but that is kind of the case i sort
of just meet people and
they're there they're fine just all
right i don't remember you unless you
really like
cross me to be honest okay so you
so that's the moment that dodie kind of
met you it sounds like
do you remember the moment that dodie
finally crossed your mind
and you met her
you know this is an actual brain problem
i really struggle with facial
recognition
and remembering people and just i tend
not to remember first encounters
that well i do remember i remember
dodie as talented musician dodie i
remember
i've maybe just manipulated her a little
yeah i
because i was working at youtube like
sort of head hunting like new
vlogger talent so i think she crossed my
radar as like wow this girl's
really good at what she does and she's
got a beautiful voice and like we should
get her in and get her collaborating
with other people so i think it was more
of a business
mindset that i was seeing here who
invited me yes
oh wow
oh my god i didn't know that yeah i knew
you didn't people
wow thanks wow i didn't know that what
the heck i thought you did you grinded
for the slow-mo guys
which is weird and also most of
most of the uk yeah like best buns
that makes sense that makes sense so
you've got great taste it sounds like
apparently i do grace because i always
wanted to oh
see now you just i'm not just being so
no yeah you're cute that's very sweet
and also
what an interesting way to meet each
other because hazel you're more on the
business side of things
dota you're on the creative side of
things and then
hey so i think we talked about this in
the last podcast but when did the shift
happen
when you moved away from like working at
the more
like uh business side of google um
i think there was always that creative
side like my whole life
i had just loved books and movies and
just storytelling in any form
and i was trying to kind of keep it
alive like through my journalism degree
i was in the drama society and like
acting and that kind of thing and then
when i worked at google i was taking
evening classes in
in writing and i think
it was that side of me that got me into
the job at youtube because i started in
sales like i was in the call center on
the phone just having angry men shout at
me
those days lovely it was honestly the
best
um but then i moved into youtube and i
think a lot of that was because i like
kind of got
it like i got the idea of content
creation and wanting to make something i
wanted to tell a story
and that's why i got along with so many
of the people who were just starting out
doing that and they taught me a lot i
mean i'm joking when i say i'm
responsible there was like
it was already you know tomska and
charlie sakurai and like so many amazing
people in the uk
doing really awesome things and i think
i don't know maybe i just got it
um and then from that they sort of cast
me in a couple things because they
really didn't know very many women
it turns out funny um and they just sort
of needed like female actresses
in stuff and i kind of started to do
that and then went oh hold on i really
enjoy this so
i started my own channel and then i
worked at youtube for a couple years
whilst doing my own channel and it made
me really good at my job
because i would get these board meetings
with like corporate people
with giving it all that and it was all
revenue revenue on bottom line and i was
like but you don't know how what
it feels like to speak to a camera or
edit yourself or put that online or get
comments back from people or like check
views or
promote yourself or like put yourself in
that kind of it's quite a vulnerable
position
so i think it made me a bit better at my
job and then i just kind of kept
doing it and i started doing short films
and um
comedy sketches and that sort of stuff
and loved it so much that eventually
i flew the nest amazing
thank you started doing it and so then
the cool thing is like you guys go from
from there this kind of working
relationship you have like a friendship
and then you have a different type of
working relationship you're directing
uh like her music video
for human right like yeah yeah what's
the difference
when you guys work on set like that
versus like
just hanging out with each other is
there a difference
i want to explain that i just oh good
god the computers had a little meltdown
i just had a little moment because i
thought you were going to go when did it
go from like
yeah you know very friendship to real
friendship and i remembered when that
was it was like oh god we're gonna
talk about that but we'll come back to
that oh i do remember
um what's it like working together
awesome it's
so great because yeah we have that
foundation
of knowing each other so well and like
on human like
i know hazel knows me very well and she
knows that she can like push me to a
certain extent also she's my friend and
cares about me so she's there to hold me
at the end
because you know me so well as yeah well
like you knew what i was trying to say
with that song
so intricately and then so conveyed it
so well
yeah it's awesome it's great similarly
i'm definitely going to write some music
for her new book which is
which is hopefully about to happen
well let's talk about the book because i
feel like hazel last time i actually saw
you in person you were talking about
starting to write the book and like i
think i announced it on your podcast
you might have i feel like you said it
oh i'm getting chills just talking about
it
uh that's so exciting now one
congratulations it's out now
uh for everyone to go get it seems like
it's
kicking ass right now yeah i have my
copy right here
yeah thank you
uh it's incredible because you kind of
did there's
a lot of i guess different ways that you
can write books and you really kind of
did this independently at first right
like you just decided you were going to
write a book
you're not looking for like people to
work with necessarily just yet like what
was that process like
uh scary i bet yeah
but also i had to be honest i kind of
been i think
the thing was i didn't really start like
my youtube career until i was 27
and then i've been writing the book like
it's kind of the process the whole
process has kind of been the past three
years so i'm in my 30s now and like i'm
you know fairly grown and i know myself
and i had been
directing sets of you know with 70
people on them and i had been
leading teams at google and so i wasn't
some like little kid who i can imagine
that that would be so daunting for like
it was daunting for me but i'm so glad
that i had all that other experience
going into it so it wasn't as scary as
it might have been
and i think it gave me the courage to
not go with a traditional
publisher which i might have been
tempted to do i think just to kind of
feel a bit safer but i didn't love
the direction publishers wanted me to go
in with it so for anyone who doesn't
know it's basically like a love story
it's told in reverse so you begin with
the breakup and then it's like little
snapshots snapshots time you get to the
end
you're broken because you know
the hype man just built it um yeah so a
lot of like the publishers i was meeting
with
were like could you tell it
chronologically and yeah did it have a
happy ending and
can we put a pink cutie cover on it and
like there's nothing wrong with pink qt
covers or any of that kind of stuff it's
just that's not a story i want to sell
so i went with a a crowdfunding
publisher called unbanned
who basically they're a platform um okay
so they don't have like the
infrastructure
of a big big publisher they're
independent they're they're small but
it's a platform
kind of like um what's it called patreon
where you
you like you have a product to sell and
you have all different pledge levels as
well so you could buy the book or you
could buy like
also an audio chapter read by me or this
that or the other so we made it quite
cool
and they gave me like complete creative
control but a lot of
help so i had an editor and a designer
and all the things that you would have
but ultimately like the book stopped
with me and
the book stopped um
wow and you can't stop
can't stop me all right so yeah yeah it
was
fun and scary but like in a good way and
what was it like because i'm sure you
must have given dodie like
chapters along the way anything to read
or do she was getting involved
she didn't see me every oh my god i saw
her right i saw her break
she sent me chapters off she finished
them and every single time i would just
send her a reply of my tears saying face
and just be like beautiful this is
beautiful i've been a number one fan
since the very beginning
i sound like so sweet it's almost like
she's won some kind of competition
to be here i honestly
i've just left this for so long and she
was so terrified she was like
what if it isn't as good as you know
you're biased and i'm like
yeah but i also have a great tasting
well the thing is i feel like you guys
can commiserate because
you like have bleeding hearts both of
you if you look at your
social media without knowing you like
you put your emotions
into everything and you are very
transparent
about a lot of things and that's like
very attractive to
a lot of people you're transparent about
things never but so
what i mean the feeling before actually
it being released to anyone other than
your friends must have been insanely
terrifying like how did you cope with
that those kind of feelings i didn't
she's been i i genuinely cannot stress
enough how
how big a part of this is even in terms
of like
the protagonist's best friend maya um
is i mean she's not a real person none
of them are she's she's kind of an
amalgamation of like the friends i've
had over the years and dodie is
a huge part of her so every time someone
leaves me a comment being like everyone
needs a maya she's so lovely i'm like
yeah it's basically
like a lot of that is her like the way
that they incorrect is very much like us
and even like some like specific little
details that made it in
um like that's a lot of it is quite
dodie um
so she's amazing and then when it came
to like so the writing process if
anything the launch was nothing compared
to the writing process which she
she sort of helped me by the hand i was
doing like several other friends as well
i have to say a lot of people were like
so supportive and they get a lot of
credit for it
but when it came to the launch yeah it
was
i was brickiness uh as we would play
back home
breaking it breaking it out
big brick got it [ __ ] it basically
um yeah because it's it's so scary it's
such a it's so
personal it's so it's more personal than
anything else and i've written quite a
lot but it's more personal than anyone
else i've ever
heard it's weird for me because i've
known this story for so long
like yeah and then for other people like
i remember doing the live stream and
someone was commenting being like
oh jocelyn blah blah and i'm like you
know about that
you have to like to like like see people
read this story
and see and like finally be in that same
world as me yeah
it was really part of me was like no i'm
not he was like
yeah yeah well it must feel like
it's the extra layer of vulnerability
that all of a sudden like even though
this is a fictitious world you've
created it's based in so much of your
real
experiences that there is so much of you
in it for people to see that you're like
are they smart enough to read between
the lines and people are
yeah they're who they are keep it there
i keep saying this but like it's it it
is fiction
and and the events are fictitious but
what i always say is like the feeling
behind it is real so if i
if i'm trying to convey a way that i've
i've felt or been made to feel in the
past
through this character that i'm sort of
having her go through
things that lead to that same emotion
happening but they're not
necessarily the same things i went
through but the feeling is definitely
real and like and then
the reason she's been so amazing is
because you get that like you know in
her
music it's so raw and you put so much of
yourself into it so like
she understood when the book was coming
out she fully understood
that's like an album launched oh god
people are going to hear my soul
i mean and on top of that just like the
uh actual state of the world that's
happening right now
while you're launching a book thank god
you guys had each other to
like be there for each other doing it
because i mean i saw you tweeting too
like
how you you've been working on this
forever and you're proud of it and you
want to celebrate it
but it also feels like an inconvenient
moment
in history to celebrate it like where do
you find
the the joy in being able to
promote and all of that and also i think
you've done it like amazingly well i
give you so much
credit for navigating this because it's
so wildly difficult right now to
and you guys are very coolly outspoken
about a lot of like social issues on
your uh social media which i think is
very cool so that must have been insane
to balance that yeah i think it was
mostly just about not wanting to be
insensitive
right this just isn't my time right now
like
blm happened literally the week ramping
up to the launch that i
had you know been waiting a long time
for and been very excited for and like
you say
years of work went into it lots of
people helped and i wanted to celebrate
that but it felt a little bit like
shush hazel your voice is not the voice
that matters right now
and give other people a platform to
speak and and just just be quiet and
give that space
to kind of blossom and yeah it was it
was a weird time because also
you know there's there's the global
stuff going on and then there's the
the micro stuff in your own personal
life as well and and it matters to me
this book matters to me and to the
people who help the other thing is like
it was crowdfunded
so but it's full of names of people who
contributed and helped make it possible
so i wanted to celebrate all that so it
was
i think i just sat with it for a couple
days like i i i really
sort of sat and felt it for a few days
and looked at as much stuff as i could
and
read as much and educated myself as much
as i could and dodi was doing the same
we were just kind of in different rooms
just trying to consume as much as
because you were watching documentaries
and
i was on the internet a lot and um
ultimately i put up a black square
one day because like everyone was doing
it and then suddenly just felt really
wrong and i took it back down i had a
real
good long think and a look at myself on
my behavior online and what i realized
was i had been so
busy trying to champion women like
that's always been my cause is sexism
and equal rights for women so i've been
so busy like
promoting authors directors poets
artists who who are female
that i didn't stop to think like holy
crap 95
of these women are white that's not good
enough that's just not good enough i
need to do better
so the way that i felt i could
incorporate it like in a genuine way
into what i do
is that since this has started to happen
i've
been filling my feed with the voices of
women of color
i think what you did was you you took it
as
like gratitude almost like it was never
really
it was never a problem it was like this
is interesting to have happened at that
same time but
yeah instead of sort of like
worrying and shutting down you you took
it as a grateful challenge and
and sort of stepped up and spoke even
louder um for voices that needed to be
heard as well
at the same time yeah i i think you did
a really really wonderful job and
as we're all trying to do the best that
we can with everything right now
uh i think it's also great to have
a piece of fiction that allows people to
kind of
you know step away from the world for a
second like you're not getting
misery and pain yeah yeah yeah exactly
come on this roller coaster you'll cry a
little bit more too
okay last question about the book why do
you want people to read this
oh why do i want people to read it um
she's just gonna hold it up
um well firstly
if you read it i make money which is
great um
it's my job um no the the funny thing
about the book was like
last time this is gonna sound really
wanky but like i did i didn't write it
to be read
necessarily like i wrote it for me and a
lot of people have said to me
in the aftermath was that really
cathartic for you like was that
therapeutic and it
it has been it's really changed my
outlook on on a lot of things and it
helps me look back
more fondly on relationships where i was
still carrying
that kind of ow that kind of just that
thing that gets you like
that's opened up a little and it just
doesn't feel as painful anymore it
softened that
um so the journey for me is kind of done
i'm kind of happy i'm like
i know why i want people i want people
to read the book
because it shows the complexities of a
real relationship i think you said this
once but like
a lot of people when they hear about the
break a break up they're like how did it
end like what was the sole reason and
this book shows
that it's just not anywhere near like
that there are so many little things
like
not only that but like from generations
of like being brought up by someone like
you'll read about like you know the
theo's mother
etc um and so yeah it's like little bits
and bobs that all build up to this thing
and also like
how although it's written from the
narrator's viewpoint like you you kind
of recognize her as biased
um and her voice is like uh yeah you
can't really trust her either because
she she's
seemed to do some sort of like dodgy
things as well it's just sort of like
a collection of moments that end up to
it
not working out and i think there's
something beautiful and so real about
that and everyone should read it to
understand complexity
oh i love it okay
before we move on i think what i've been
hearing a lot of
from people is that it depicts mental
health
in a very real way for them and i didn't
i think part of
what i was so scared of like you were
talking about right before the launch
like oh god people are going to read it
was those topics like it touches on
sexuality identity trauma abuse
mental health um and it was like am i
representing
people well and in a sensitive way and
i struggle with reading material or
watching material that that triggers me
so i wanted to be able to talk about
those things in a way that wouldn't be
triggering for someone but that they
could
hopefully glean a little insight into it
um so either they're going through it
and it helps them feel seen
or they're they never have been through
it but it helps them maybe understand a
friend or a loved one
um or just you know what a lot of people
go through so i think that's that's
kind of been the nicest thing and i
guess the reason i would say
to read it if you're curious about that
kind of stuff it's not about that
um yeah but it comes up for the
protagonist quite a lot and i
hope i've kind of told it in the real
way and told
told their story in a way that like
dirty says like it's not like
why'd you break up oh well he cheated or
she ran over on my puppy with her car
like you don't you rarely have this one
thing it's it's years and years and as
you say generational stuff of like how
you were brought up and
what your parents went through and every
all of that that you
two people are bringing and it either
yeah oh it looks at the human condition
in a really complex way i love
that i love the idea of like
understanding
why we do things based on our upbringing
and based on
like our family and nature versus
nurture and all that fun stuff ooh
that's very exciting
okay uh we're gonna take one quick break
when we get back i gotta find out what
it's like
with you two living together i wanna
know all about it
we'll be right back with more not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
that's my impression of an alarm because
time's up
it's about time to turn that dream of
yours into reality and squarespace is
going to help you do it
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project we're all trying
out new things as best as we can in the
times that we have been dealt
currently do you want to start a new
business do you want to showcase your
work do you want to publish content
do you want to sell products or more
squarespace is the tool for you
they have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers
and the ability to customize just about
anything with a few clicks so you can
easily
make a beautiful website all by yourself
they have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online
and analytics that help you grow your
site in real time
and everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box you don't even have
to think about it there's nothing to
patch
or upgrade ever and buying domains is
simple and you can get all the help you
need with their 24
7 award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms
everyone they're helping turn great
ideas into something real
so head to squarespace.com grace for a
free trial and when you are ready to
launch
use the offer code grace to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
grace offer code grace
okay let's talk about the two of you you
lived together
you occasionally worked together how
long have you guys lived together
yeah there's been bits and bobs where we
haven't but i've
always been about that was it one of you
that like kind of proposed
to the other one the idea of living
together that's on camera somewhere i
think
yeah i was i was filming a series called
time of the month which was like a month
and a half vlog series back in like what
was it 2015 yes 16 yeah and there's like
a new year's eve party where we're just
hammered
and we're just lying on the ground in
this like fairy like
it's like pink and yeah do you want to
look at it yeah
why not yeah i'm really good
that was it it was very easy and what uh
what is the strangest thing about the
other one
with living together if there is a
strange hobby a strange little like
okay hazel likes the dishwasher stacked
a very particular way
very particular and like sometimes it
gets
sometimes it's funny like if i get it
wrong and sometimes it genuinely
bothers me because i'm like listen i'm
trying my best okay
um what else oh when hazel cleans
she doesn't she sort of puts all of her
stuff
in very neat piles but she never puts it
away it's just sort of like
organizing no that's me too uh i call my
house this is a piles house
it's a piles household yeah everything
it looks from the naked eye
like a [ __ ] mess but i know exactly
where everything
smiles yeah she knows i don't know about
your weird things
really you it's always like so many you
said something the other day
i was worried about yeah but i'm not
going to say that on there what was that
about oh
god we can skip over now let me think
that's going to be something
you're very just you're a very you have
a lot of idiosyncrasies like you have a
lot
of quirks as a human so to just pick out
one
it's almost like it just seems sh it is
her the collection of strange little
things it is makes up
so maybe one almost feels odd but we do
you have a character named goblin goatee
yes okay i wanna yeah tell me about this
she well
look goblin dodie is a version of dodie
who um enjoys mac and cheese i did
uh her posture is not good
and she um sort of skulks about the
house always in hunt
on the hunt for food and if you if you
have food and she hears the rustling of
like a
crisp packet or anything she's in there
and she's almost claw-like she's a bit
hunched
um yeah she she just turns into this
character
sometimes and i will find her like often
over her laptop as well she'll sort of
shove one knee up here and be like
hunched over the laptop
and you come in and it's almost like you
you've let light
into the room for the first time in
weeks
yeah so that's that's judge
this is an unintentional character
this just kind of takes you over
occasionally
yeah she didn't she never means to be
goblin doggy just every once in a while
you
it shows up everyone has a goblin
there's a goblin grace
oh yeah yeah for sure yeah i call myself
i'm like a little raccoon uh
yeah if i smoke a little too much weed
it's just like
all of a sudden my boyfriend finds me
just in the pantry like
touching all of the snacks just being
like taking
way too long to decide on something that
he knows i already know in my mind what
i want but i just want to see what else
is there
yeah yeah yeah those are important
decisions
exactly um is there a goblin hazel
yeah or is there is there an alter ego
that hazel has that's akin to goblin
dodie
i'm not really sure i definitely have
slob days
like yeah i say soda my life is slob day
yeah and then sometimes i put on a dress
and some makeup
absolutely yeah i get dressed mostly
every day
hazardously yeah i don't get dressed no
in this box my um is in this horrible
scraped back bun and like no makeup
and just a strange assortment of pajamas
and then a blanket around here and socks
and stuff you lie out on your bed like
so long laptop
here yeah that's my general day-to-day
existence
occasionally i'll get on the yoga mat
and take some photos for instagram and
make it look like i do things but i
don't do things
oh yeah are you guys both into yoga i am
now
dirty's getting there okay how's that
yeah how's i've seen hazel your photos
on instagram it's very impressive to me
i'm not a yoga person but it looks cool
dodie have you you've started your yoga
journey i have yes
okay and how is it going i
so i get really pissed off about it
because sometimes like
like we do adrian obviously yoga with
adrian she's just the one
okay and she just sort of like does
these things she'll like relax in these
positions where she's just like chatting
away like
maybe like a huge lunge and she's like
if you want you can like do this maybe
do this it's kind of like this thing
that happened and i'm like sweating like
shaking
i've never seen anyone else get angry
i was gonna say my leg doesn't bend that
way
so we don't do yoga anymore we began
with me trying to get her to do it with
me and then a few sessions and i was
like would you mind if i
when i do it myself this is quite an
important like
quality me time in my day and i felt bad
asking that but she
said the other day it was a conversation
thing where you were like
okay we're very honest with each other
what'd you say was that our mind yeah
we were talking about yoga and then
there was a bit of silence and then
hazel was like
you know i recognize there's a part of
me that wants to be mad that you also
enjoy a yoga because then i'm like
what's my thing that's my thing i know
that's so stupid
and i was like i get it i forced the
[ __ ] literally as we're talking i just
noticed i
forced this [ __ ] on her she's got a new
earth by eckhart tolle
and that is all apart by pima chodron
who is a full of a buddhist
monk a female buddhist monk and i i make
her
read this stuff and here but and i
talked to her constantly about the
podcast that i'm listening to in my my
crazy spiritual journey
and she puts up with it and that's not
because that's
that's really sweet i mean because of
quarantine i'm sure you guys have had to
spend
more time together than you've possibly
ever spent consistently
together and the fact that you're in
this high spirits whether it's fake or
not
seems pretty good it's not fake it's
just shortness
we can do this in first um i love it
i am someone who needs people all the
time like i
like being on tour is the best part of
my life because it's just
constant people you wake up with people
you go breakfast people you sound check
with people you play with people
yeah with people it's just like constant
people everywhere
that sounds like a nightmare tonight
always around hazel i'm like hey
you're just into my room i'll look up
and she'll be in the door frame like
this is like what do you want she won't
know
go away yeah i struggle i've recently
learned that i'm
a very outgoing introvert so in my whole
life i thought i was an extrovert and
i'm like i'll talk to the wall but also
i'm irish you can drop me in the middle
of any group i'll just start talking
sure but like yeah i've recently learned
that i very much get my energy
alone so she goes for once you visit
people
that's good she tries to give me space
bless her heart
that's respectful um jody what's going
on with music for you right now are
there plans in the future to tour again
is there is that hard impossible to
predict at this point
um there are plans there are actually a
bunch of plans
okay one's a backup in case
the us doesn't so it's shout out it's
gonna launch them into space
it doesn't yeah on behalf of the united
states i'm sorry it doesn't look like
we're getting our [ __ ] together anytime
soon
sorry yeah so we will see
music wise i mean i keep saying
everywhere but i'm straight up just
sitting
on a huge thing um but
i could just release into the wild this
sounds like the worst euphemism
new secret project which may or may not
be an album i couldn't possibly say
impossible to tell stunning i have
experienced it
i won't even say in what through what
sensory medium
um i have experienced it and it is so
beautiful so painfully gorgeously
beautiful
it is really that it brings me to tears
every time i experience it and i want to
be unleashed on the world so that you
can have it too but
that's so exciting is there a
time frame in which this might be
released or is there that still up in
the air
yes got it okay no further questions
it's not too far to be like okay
let's just say if it zoomed by
as fast as the beginning of this year
did and now that we're in july
dude right no time at all it'll be
before america's got her [ __ ] together
great wonderful i can't wait
uh have you guys felt because like
you've been stuck inside
right that and i've been looking at your
instagrams today
and they're curated beautifully does it
feel a little bit like a return
to like old kind of youtube stuff or old
like social media stuff of like just
having
to only be inside to only be in
your space and trying to make the best
of it oh
interesting it's really interesting what
do you think do you want a sec to think
or are you
um let me think or maybe this has been
kind of what you've been doing
the whole time and so it doesn't feel
that far off from yeah i guess for me
like i've been so busy like um
like i just had like back-to-back things
and i never really had time to sit down
and write and make anything
um but when quarantine happened i had
like these months of time so i started
this project called
elosia where i would like write a song
i'd say it was called elosio because it
was called a lot of songs in april
very vague no promises made um but i
ended up like writing
like six seven songs and like putting
them up
and people were like wow it feels like
the old days when you actually used to
make videos i was like i know
they were brilliant yeah they're very
good they're really good yeah
every one of them they weren't even just
throwing they were like genuinely good
i stupidly got more ambitious i started
a youtube series called badisi
which was a video every day in
self-isolation little did i know
self-isolation would be you know 600
days later
so i think i managed about 20 days and
then
actually a lovely thing happened it was
because the option
the option for the rights to the series
of the book jesus i've worded that so
badly
a production company bought the rights
to the book uh to potentially make into
a tv series
so amazing i was tasked with writing the
pilot script so i
explained this to the lovely people on
youtube and what's nice is like our
audiences are just so cool they haven't
minded at
all what it's been like we've been
figuring it out for a couple months and
like sometimes there's content sometimes
there's not like you said you did a
bunch of songs and then you kind of took
a
step back i did all those videos and i
explained like i'm gonna need to not but
then there's a big book launch
so yeah they've just been really really
lovely and there it hasn't felt like
there's been any
pressure to post necessarily but i also
feel like people are so
grateful when you do like they're just
like thank you for
entertaining and spreading some
self-love
yeah no totally i mean we're all burning
through
so much content so much quick more
quickly than i think we would
normally so everything is appreciated
which is very cool okay
if if okay this is for each of you to
answer about the other
if if you were care packages what would
that care package look like
wait to give to the other person or if
we so
if you were a care pack so if dodie was
a care package like what would that look
like if someone was given a dodie care
package
like what would that have inside of it
oh my god and if hazel was a care
package what would that look like
my own face
i was like i have to answer this there's
so much see i want to go away and think
about it and jot down some notes and
like write something really beautiful
and come
i mean it's kind of like a starter pack
right i know what hazel is hazel
is like low lighting
low noise like crushed tones
like oils burning um
like soft bed sheets and like okay
meditation and calming phrases
um let me think what else and also like
i don't know
oh good tea like well broods well
brewed well the nicest thing anyone's
like a well-brewed tea yeah
you are welcome slightly sugar lots of
awesome
nice yeah i would say you're just
very calming you're also a big hug
you're a big hug
that's really sweet yes oh my god
all day actually i was going to come in
and ask you for i was going to ask you
about enough to tell me oh my god
we'll hug after we'll have a look
sometimes we have a little puddle and
it's nice
we just get on the bed and we spoon and
then we swap over and we spoon
i mean equal opportunity spooning i'm
all for it
right you saw him my care package i am
sorry
she knows me so well um jodie is
lightness lightness yeah in
otherwise in an otherwise like heavy
oppressive
atmosphere when when i'm like
catastrophizing dodie can come in and
just
lighten something it's almost like she
turns on a switch
i'm supposed to be making these into
real objects in a care package uh
it's okay it can be amorphous it can be
descriptive okay it's okay
she's like a really good giggle she's
like a really really good like
proper belly laugh that kind of rolls
your ribs
and you you you end up like wiping my
tears after and you can't remember what
the problem was before because you've
just been laughing so hard yourself oh
that's great
but you're like and also like uh a
cat that sort of crawls up on your
laptop
on you while you're from work and just
wants the glove
and you love the cap but sometimes you
want it to not be on your thing
but then when it's there you're like oh
you
yeah oh that's very
sweet those are i you definitely can't
put a cat in a care package but i think
those were really beautifully
described it would be like
schroedinger's care package
and i would worry for the cat sage but
yeah um
we're gonna take one last break when we
get back i have a bunch of twitter
questions
for you ladies so we'll be right back
with more not too deep
[Music]
okay before we get into these twitter
questions i'm going to ask you ladies
with two questions i ask every single
guest that's on the podcast
i believe you've answered these before i
have no idea what your answers were
yeah i'm just going to assume they're
going to be different but uh the first
question is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at
oh yeah i remember
the same as it was last time it's not
donald trump is it
i actually didn't say trump because i
felt like
that was like too obvious so i said uh
that betty
what was her name buddy
that's how much impact you've had in my
life betty
but yeah it was it's this similar if
there were a collective
sort of evil republican face yeah
that that one would be um katie hopkins
she's just this
awful awful woman who just says
anything bad literally anything and i'm
sure she'll change her mind on whatever
you think is good she'll just say the
bad thing
she's just the worst person alive and
i'm not sure if she'll ever change but
i sure would like to see some cold
spaghetti in her horrible face
yeah that sounds like necessary i it's
that's so frustrating and so confusing
to me when people are like that
uh it takes so much energy to be that
way like it's
exhausting it seems like it takes more
effort
somehow convinced herself that like
there's value in
the attention of being evil so yeah
well on a lighter note the other
question that every guest gets asked is
to tell us your worst pant [ __ ]
story
or like a bathroom close call but you
can only use three words or
three small phrases or a combination so
mine for example is college jogging
front lawn i remember you saying that
last time and thinking that's way better
than
what i'm gonna i know you can come up
with it
it can be a close call it can be i've
never
okay celebrity
okay uh
recording
[Laughter]
obvious
[Laughter]
i don't know whether i'm allowed to i
definitely smile
i know i know the story because i know
everything so after
like it was that time and i'll be like
oh yeah let's keep it oh yeah
oh yeah i missed it but we can keep it
in
in mystery i i actually i don't have one
but can i can i do one
from from a friend of course yeah sure
you're gonna have to go on okay summer
topshop skirt
you know who you are yes oh no
you wonderful wonderful woman it really
is an awful
yeah any story that you're telling on
behalf of a friend [ __ ] their pants
has to be
terrible that i remembered it
it's vivid
oh
okay um let's get into these twitter
questions i have a bunch for you ladies
oh a couple last night and i was like
tempted to just start doing a q a i know
i know you guys some of you guys like um
sorry to spoil it but you're not
supposed to answer them here and i'm
like
i know i know i went through this
morning i was like
so they're just straight up answering
them on twitter what am i talking about
oh it's all good okay if you had to
exist in either wet socks or constantly
damp hair for the rest of your life
which would you choose constantly damp
hair hair
damn hair yeah yeah you know it could be
a yeah get this one
yeah you look like a kardashian
this is constantly a little damp hair
although i worry it would look a bit
greasy but i'd just be like oh i've just
come out the shower i'm just so clean
yeah people be like she loves to shower
every time i see her her hair is wet
i just thought about my feet being in
wet socks all the time actually made me
feel
awful that would be terrible anything go
on it's terrible
um someone wants to know most fun
quarantine activity
it's not saying a lot is it yeah
so you guys like fun or
i don't know that we do i'm just going
to say
this is boring but writing i like
writing music
decorating my wall with ikea flowers
she's been decorating a lot
yes i have decorating like redoing
things and like
yeah and stuff that's a great activity
oh my god binge watching the sorry girls
on youtube
oh i love them we've been watching a lot
of kind of
series which has been fun we've got
did the second series of dead to me in
like a day oh my god
literally a mess a hot mess but we loved
it
nice i've enjoyed getting dolled up and
having cocktail evenings we haven't done
that in a while do oh sure
just getting done for no reason i'm just
going to your balcony getting drunk
taking loads of people having a night
taking a lot of photos
that's what made me that's what made me
think that london had opened back up
again
because it looked like you guys were
actually going out
wow
sometimes we go out on the roof terrace
nice
that's a great idea but we are very very
very lucky that there's a big roof
terrace in this building
and everybody shares it but not many
people go out there
yeah like i'm so shocked by how few
people are right there so i can go out
there like we've exercised or do yoga
out there
so yeah it's like we don't have a garden
so it's been really nice to do that
that's so so wonderful to have that
uh someone wants to know what is the
dumbest thing you have argued or just
had a disagreement over
the freezer although actually that's
probably the most intelligent thing
we've had
oh about the it's a really
i don't i was okay if you put
if you put ice cubes if you fill up a
whole ice cube tray
uh-huh is that going to take longer to
freeze
than like one ice cube like one
oh i don't truly i don't know but that
sounds like a vegan
question we did tweet vsauce and hang
and uh they told me i was wrong she was
wrong i was wrong
it would take longer to freeze more
stuff that wasn't really an argument it
wasn't it was
have we haven't debate we don't really
[Music]
argue
don't really argue that's good
sometimes one of us gets pissy about
something and then we sort of cry it out
yeah but it feels like you guys are just
honest with each other in real time so
that arguments don't brew
that seems to be that it's incredible
it's almost like open honest
communication is the key to any good
relationship
and someone should tell people this yeah
because i feel like we don't know
i feel like a lot of people are confused
on that or don't believe that that's
true
i just don't believe i couldn't i cannot
imagine doing this
with any of my former romantic partners
i mean obviously they're former for a
reason
but like the idea like i can't imagine
doing this with
most humans to be honest but dodie and i
just
we have a dance yeah yeah thank god
that's great
okay what's the best movie you've seen
during quarantine
if there's one uh
i know what i'm going to say i saw a
portrait of a lady on fire
right before this quarantine it was like
we went to see it together
yeah like two days before we quarantined
i don't know if this counts because
i'm going to say because it needs to be
watched by everybody it's gay
french gothic gothic romance beautiful
oh it's just the most gorgeous love
story between these two women
and it's like slightly overwrought in
the best possible way
and um it's female director female dop
and it's beautiful and every single
frame looks like an oil thing it's
gorgeous
it's gorgeous oh good to know and a good
recommendation
okay here's a little bit more serious of
a question
uh do you feel restricted by your image
for instance dodie as a cutesy happy
ukulele gal
and hazel being wine mom with dark humor
um a hundred and a million ten billion
percent yes
really yeah absolutely i my whole life
is so
large
that's the cold open you got it
she's done that
i feel like that's like the opening
scene to your documentary about you
yep there we go music
i get that you're like you're complex
human beings
and like and on the internet it's hard
to
like make sure people know that i can be
a real piece of [ __ ]
and like it's hard when i know that
and people are like you're a perfect
angel and i'm like please stop
that every time i read that i just feel
worse
which is not very nice and obviously
like it's a very nice thing to say but
like
i almost want to like type back and be
like you don't know
yeah me i've written that down i've
written like this whole list of [ __ ]
i've done
just because you don't you don't owe
that to the world and like i'm watching
her go through this a lot of the time
and it's difficult because i know what
it's like to have
demons from your past or have things
like moments you regret things you feel
guilty for things you wish had gone a
different way or you feel at fault for
and to the process the journey that you
go on to like forgive yourself for those
things and make friends with yourself
and i'm not even
she hasn't killed anybody that
you is important about and i watch her
get told she's an angel all day every
day and it like
kind of hinders you on that journey to
figuring yourself out because you she
almost feels like she needs
i have to tell everybody that i'm not
perfect it's like you really you really
don't they should just know that you're
complex yeah because people are and
people [ __ ] up and that's okay because
that's how we learn
but yeah yeah a lot for you um i also
like every time someone expects me to
like something because it fits into my
character i want to reply and be like
actually no i hate it i like this big
dark thing you know
they just sent me pictures of dogs and i
liked them
they are fine i think this is more of an
internal struggle than it is anyone
else's
problem yeah yeah but it is but it is
hard right because i'm
i'm wildly fascinated right now about
everyone that's been doing stuff on the
internet for you know years and years
and years like how it's affected all of
us in different ways and i think
it has deeply affected all of us in
different ways
and it's so you i i feel you on that
power struggle of like
feeling like you want to tell everyone
exactly who you are in the rawest way
possible but then also feeling like you
don't owe that information to everyone
yeah for sure it's so confusing i'm
actually
going through therapy about it now it's
just like knowing
what is mine to keep but also kind of
trying to combat the guilt of
seemingly owing that to people yeah it's
so confusing and i think what's weird is
like i grew up as a fan like
i was a kid when uh in like the early
youtube days and i just watched all of
these people
and put them on this insane pedestal it
wasn't even a pedestal they just lived
in this dream world
and i couldn't even imagine them as
human characters outside of the video
and i would say that i did but i really
didn't
um so it's interesting knowing that and
now living through it and
yeah but you're also just young it's
kind of it's not but it's kind of that
thing you get like as you grow up
everyone realizes that their parents are
human
like you have that moment where you go
oh you did
you do some [ __ ] you know you kind of
you [ __ ] up a bit there and it's
hard to get your head around that and
they're kind of similar in that they're
people you
grew up idolizing and seeing as sort of
you know guardian
type people in your life you look up to
and trust and they do no wrong
um i'm lucky that i'm old enough but
that didn't really happen i didn't have
the internet as such so
like i had but not social media the way
that we do now so like
i couldn't interact with the cast of
buffy or star
when i was a trek i just saw the
characters and that was it
i'm so thankful for that because i see
you go through it now and it's like
i can't imagine i see my nieces going
through this now and
one of them is like on tick tock now and
she's like she's great she's actually so
funny but she's talking about like i'm
gonna be a tick tocker i'm like
no you're [ __ ] not you're gonna go to
school missy and you're gonna
learn something and then if you want to
think about maybe that when you're 20
you can yeah yeah it's scary
it's very scary it's fascinating and
scary and i don't know what like the
right
thing to do is because it's also
individualized you know
so the only thing i've tried to do is
like
remove myself from the internet yeah and
it doesn't feel right
yeah that's just kind of going through
it at the moment grace have you been
finding this during lockdown is it like
a love for you
uh no i'm just thinking like you know
i've talked to a lot of people about
different career paths different
pivoting
figuring out different things and also
just like every day opening twitter and
watching the world
burn in so many ways and watching like
macro stuff and micro
like youtube platform stuff happen at
the same time it's just like
i'm gonna just consider myself that
homer simpson gif of him just like
walking back into the bus
yeah i think that's honestly it's part
of why i've had such an emphasis on
self-care like in my own life and then
then by extension that's leading on to
everything i'm doing online
and in the book a little bit but like
yeah i kind of
like i say i'm just i'm not a bit older
and more mature so i've kind of gone
through my [ __ ] a bit and i
i spent a couple years doing some very
heavy processing in therapy um
so i've come out the other side of it
now a bit stronger myself and having all
these tools and techniques
to take care of myself when [ __ ] does
hit the fan so i feel like
i'm that little bit more able to kind of
contend with it or just close twitter
and you know not go there today or
like i'm reading so much like i'm joking
about these books but like honestly
reading out of buddhism
and um consciousness and awareness and
listening to like russell brands
podcasts and
all that kind of stuff really helps you
to kind of just disengage sometimes and
be like this stuff is important
but also you need to reserve your energy
to fight
the good fight and it's okay to take a
step back from that sometimes
and look after yourself it's really
important that people know that right
now i think
a hundred hundred percent well i think
that's a great
note to end this episode if not too deep
but before
before you ladies go usually um when we
do this in person
we give our guests a personalized
fortune cookie from us to them
because they've made time for us but now
we're doing virtual fortune cookies so i
believe melissa has sent
yours to an email look at them together
i'm so sad this is ending okay
so this is way our collective fortune
cookie
yes okay you're ready
[Laughter]
pegasus boobs certainly has a nice ring
to it
and maybe a great title to a sequel
perhaps
perhaps perhaps that's the perfect
flushing cookie
i'm just so happy about that
i don't have if you'd like to explain it
you can okay
basically i was trying to figure out how
to top up the heating
um and hazel sent all the info on the
text message but you know
like i was like okay we need like a word
that i can like easily
search for the next time i need to find
this information and
hazel was like boobs i was like
no no boobs i
found that like it would be buried and
then she was like pegasus and i was like
i don't know how to spell that so i was
like typing pegasus
pegasus
it just looks like we're going slowly
yeah yeah it's great and then also
knowing that you guys live together and
have those same kind of text exchange
is is very very funny well usually when
we're in the same room that's my
favorite thing
both the text conversations that i post
online that we've had are when we're on
opposite ends of the sofa yeah
and we're just giggling we're just on
twitter just like giggling
that's fantastic okay for everyone that
doesn't know where can people find you
find the book find
possibly new music and everything else
that you're up to
um my name is dodie d-o-d-i-e and you
can find me pretty much anywhere by
typing that in
or doddleoddle but that's really
outdated now i'm 25 years old yeah we
all spoke some bad names for some stuff
way back when
i am hazel zdl or z-e-l depending
where you want to do that um hazel hey
my book is called out of love
so if you google that you should be able
to find it on book depository or amazon
or various places
also bookshop.org actually they help
support local bookshops so if you buy a
book there
they then contribute very percentage of
the charity to lots of different local
bookshops so that's a good one too if
you can get it there
we're currently out of stock because
they all sold out but we are printing
more i don't know when this is going out
but hopefully there will be more back uh
on shelves and in stores and my
youtubers youtube.com
for slash hazel and the hazel haze and
everything else that's it really
awesome well thank you guys so much for
making time and congratulations on
everything your friendship the book a
new secret project
all of it i'm very excited for you guys
her secret project is so amazing and i
can't wait until it's out and everybody
can experience it
thank you yay all right we'll see you
guys next time another episode of not
too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music